tras una larga noche de negociaciones en
un ambiente más bien relajado está
pasando algo
no secuestramos a nadie por si se lo
están preguntando los tratamos bien la
francia insumisa confía en alcanzar un
acuerdo con el resto de la izquierda de
cara a las legislativas
avanzamos bien y somos optimistas y
esperamos que en las próximas horas que
puedan hacerse un poco más largas
en las reuniones con todo el mundo
incluidos los comunistas así es
de los cuatro principales partidos de
izquierda la francia insumisa y los
ecologistas y alcanzaron un acuerdo que
implica salario mínimo a 1400 euros
netos jubilación a los 60 años y la
posibilidad de desobedecer ciertas
reglas europeas un punto de discordia
con el partido socialista sin embargo
esta mañana el portavoz de los
socialistas también se mostró optimista
sobre la cuestión europea llegaremos a
un entendimiento porque lo que vemos es
que se han dado pasos y la cuestión
europea ha fracturado a la izquierda
desde hace 30 años así que no vamos a
resolverlo todo en una semana y
evidentemente formar una coalición
política no significa pensar todo es lo
mismo yo no entré en esta conversación
siendo de la francia y sumisa ni saldré
siendo de ella
permanecer fiel a los fundamentos del
partido y aliarse con la francia
insumisa son los equilibrios que
enfrenta el partido comunista convencido
de llegar a un punto en común entre las
formaciones a pesar de las divergencias
sobre el tema nuclear no hay una fecha
límite para el anuncio pero la francia
insumisa se fija el 7 de mayo como plazo
para el nombramiento de los candidatos
de esta nueva unión de izquierdas el
mismo día de la ceremonia de investidura
de macrón